welcome to hope the heli constable grant
please call me Nathan oh please call me
Abigail Laurie Lachlan dropped by
Hallmark Channel after her alleged
involvement in a massive College bribery
scam you get very emotional about our
show I'm really proud of our show how
far we've come in a statement to ET on
Thursday hallmark said they would no
longer be working with the actress
saying in part quote we are no longer
working with Laurie Lachlan and have
stopped development of all productions
that air on the crown media family
Network
this means garage-sale mysteries are you
saying that someone hit him in the face
and then someone else hit him from
behind Laurie is also a co-executive
producer and one of the stars on
Hallmark's long-running drama series
when calls the heart a new episode will
not air on Sunday March 17th as the
network evaluates quote all creative
options related to the series that life
goes on and we're there to tell
heartfelt stories you know that will
make you happy and touch your heart this
news comes on the heels of Laurie's
arrest on Wednesday she was taken into
custody by FBI agents for allegedly
paying $500,000 to have her two
daughters Isabella and Olivia designated
as recruits to USC as crew team et
obtained a statement from USC on
Thursday confirming that both girls are
still enrolled quote USC is conducting a
case-by-case review for current students
and graduates that may be connected to
the scheme alleged by the government and
will make informed decisions as those
reviews are completed however TMZ
alleges Isabella and Olivia have decided
to withdraw as students
[Music]